your attention please
let the feast begin
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
i felt impotent and out of control which
i really hate
i needed to find sanctuary in a place
where i could gather my thoughts and
regain my strength
[Music]
it would make your eyes look bigger
[Music]
hmm it would make my haircut look more
expensive
you'd wear it with everything it would
be an investment
you would walk into that oled interview
confident confident and
poised poised the girl
in the green scarf
the green scarf please roast quail with
brioche stuffing
and the braised lambshang with blood
orange
relish blood orange relish
now now that all sounds so good will he
have the same specials tomorrow night
no chef gda never creates the same money
twice
well i guess i better try more tonight
then
toots all
too baby too sweet
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
chopsticks
[Music]
what are we gonna do the question isn't
what are we going to do the question is
what aren't we going to do
don't say we're not going to take the
car home please don't say we're not
going to take the car
please don't if you had access to a car
like this
would you take it back right away
neither would i
this weekend is about sisterhood and
connecting with the divine
in all of us so i hope you'll all find
your bliss
starting with an all paid shopping spree
at the fashion boutique
[Applause]
y'all i think mine's on backwards or
maybe the other me has a little more
going on upstairs
just feels like something's missing
maybe two things
no just one
[Music]
is chocolate that's chocolate that's
chocolate a chocolate river that's the
most fantastic thing i've ever seen
10 000 gallons an hour and look at my
waterfall
that's the most important thing
[Applause]
it's mixing my chocolate it's actually
churning my chocolate
you know no other factory in the world
mixes its chocolate by waterfall
but it's the only way if you want it
just right
happy birthday son dad
this is your day go have fun i love you
guys
you're awesome
[Music]
yay
[Music]
you